[Music]
i can kind of walk you through an
exercise that i do with them maybe
helpful if you think let's do it all
right
great so this is one that i actually
started with my wife
and we were talking about our rich life
and it's hard when you start talking
about your rich life because you don't
even know where to start
many of us have spent our entire lives
being told what we can't do with our
money
so when you ask people what they want to
do the answers are fairly facile
you know the whole foods is an example
so what i did was i said okay
let's take separate pieces of paper and
let's write down
in the next 10 years what's on our
bucket list
and let's just write it down and we took
10-15 minutes
and the way that i thought of this was i
was inspired by stephen king's
national book club speech now he was
living in a trailer
with his wife and he was running out of
money
and he got a job offer to be a teacher
and his wife said to him will you be
able to write
and he said no i won't but at least
it'll allow us to pay the bills
and she instantly said well then you
can't do it
wow and so that chilling moment
and then fast forward just a little bit
in the future he signs
a massive deal for his first book a
massive deal
he gets the check brings it home to his
wife
in their trailer and he said we sat
there
we looked at the check we talked about
what we were going to do with the money
and we cried he said it was one of the
most beautiful conversations of his life
and i love that i love the idea that
money can be this thing that lets us do
more
not less it lets us dream bigger lets us
be more adventurous more
generous so i started off with my wife i
said let's just write down our bucket
list items
okay so we come back after 15 minutes
she had some interesting ones she wanted
to learn another language
that was just individually for herself
together
you know we wanted to i think i wrote
down i want to design a house
with you because she's very creative and
we're both into design
and we wanted to have a beautiful
10-year wedding anniversary
in india we know the exact place we know
all the people that we want to bring
with us
great we're talking about this we're
loving it we're having a blast
and i said let's pick a couple of these
and let's
put a dollar value to them so we picked
the
ten year wedding anniversary and i said
okay
pick a number there's no way to know the
right number but just pick a number what
you think it'll cost
so she kind of takes a second i take a
second and
the numbers that we picked were
hilariously different
my number was something like 5 to 10
times
bigger than the number my wife picked
and she looked uncomfortable like
visibly uncomfortable yeah i was going
to ask you if there's an asymmetry
of wealth i would imagine the person who
has
fewer resources may be very nervous
about actually speaking honestly or
adding big items or offering big numbers
well you're totally right
most people are afraid of dreaming about
their rich life
at all because they feel that once they
write it down
or tell someone if they don't achieve it
then they're a failure
but in my opinion that's just going
through life playing defense
and i'd rather play offense so what i
said to my wife is like look
neither of us know what this is actually
going to cost we just made these numbers
up
but if we're going to choose a number
let's go with the bigger one why because
we have a lot of time we have eight plus
years to save and invest for this
two i think we can do it i know what we
can accomplish together we could do it
and three
wouldn't it be magical to be able to
take all of our friends and family
the people who can't afford it just go
to the airport and the ticket will be
there for you
wouldn't that be amazing and so really
coming back to that
vision instead of well it's actually
gonna be seven percent return and i
don't know
no this is a vision exercise so she
begrudgingly said
okay i i will say that
one year later my wife has done an
amazing job working on her money
psychology
and we kind of revisited this and she
said
oh yeah like now i know without a doubt
we can hit that number
easily and that's when you're really
aligned with your partner where the two
of you are rowing in the same direction
it's not one person saying come on but
it's both of us saying oh yeah we could
do this
so let me ask may i ask you a very
personal uncomfortable
possibly uncomfortable question and then
you can tell me okay
so you said we can hit the number right
was there a discussion with some of
these items of how each
party sort of contributes to that big
goal
right even though you're not getting
into immediately the nitty-gritty i
understand it's a vision exercise but
since you're using the example i figured
i might as well ask
you guys i bet this is something that is
going to be an inevitable
topic that people have to navigate okay
i'm glad you asked and i'll definitely
share how we did it
so i think that the reason that we came
up with these
joint goals like a 10-year wedding
anniversary
is that we both want to contribute to it
okay we want to contribute
proportionally based on income
but we both want to contribute to it
the thing about you know my wife wants
to learn a certain language
i'm not contributing to that she makes
what language
just out of curiosity spanish okay cool
yeah she's taking a class she's doing a
great job nice
and she decided to get her own tutor and
that's her thing and she's covering that
on her own and i'm
thrilled i have my own stuff that i pay
for again we have our join accounts and
our separate accounts
but i will say that the reason that i
wanted to
have this exercise is that when we meet
once a month to talk about our finances
we have something to look forward to
we have an exact number that we are
saving and investing
together for and we look at it it's
almost like one of those progress bars
okay we're four percent of the way there
oh my gosh we're
now eight percent of the way there and
we can see that this goal which was so
big originally we're actually just
chipping away at it day by day
that's magic
you